estuvo brevemente en Francia
participando de un festival por la
ecología
[Aplausos]
y El Comando por el apruebo en París
invitó a la lingüista mapuche a un
banderazo a favor del proyecto de
constitución
Elisa loncon que presidió durante meses
la comisión encargada de la redacción
del texto constitucional defiende el
trabajo realizado
cuento importante para
están todos los ojos puestos en Chile
Porque nuestro país
se puso de acuerdo para redactar una
nueva constitución y esa nueva
constitución fue redactada en democracia
que tiene el consenso de todos y de
todas
incluyendonos a los pueblos indígenas
exiliados de la dictadura de pinochet o
jóvenes que vinieron recientemente por
trabajo estudios los chilenos en Francia
mantienen más que nunca el vínculo con
su país en un momento histórico sigue
siendo nuestro país lo segundo y quizás
más importantes que la nueva
constitución nos da nuevos derechos a
nosotros como chileno en el extranjero
Hasta mañana vamos a poder incluso tener
nuestros diputados desde el extranjero
un chat de WhatsApp es la manera en que
Los partidarios del rechazo en Francia
han elegido para compartir ideas antes
del domingo lo creó Bernardo abogado que
está detrás también de otras iniciativas
como la homologación del carnet de
conducir chileno en Francia
la convención Constituyente no fue Y
quién quiere criticar a nadie etcétera
Pero no fue un reflejo de lo que es
chile y un país democrático y un país en
que se en que hemos tenido una tradición
de diálogo y respecto también al
contenido que mucha gente no se ha
sentido identificada con el tema como la
pluralidad plurinacionalidad con
respecto a la igualdad de la ley y el
hecho de que se categoriza un poco los
chilenos por su origen no sabemos cómo
eso va a ser
puesto en la ley en la vida cotidiana
los chilenos más de 20.000 chilenos
viven en este país es el noveno que
acoge más chilenos en el mundo unos 3000
se han inscrito para votar pero al haber
Solo dos locales de sufragio el voto no
es obligatorio